from Christmas kisses to black hood hit
and misses I'm gifting use all the
holiday goodies on Sweetwater secrets
[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Ileana Galera and you're
watching the Sweetwater secrets
after-show for episode 209 chapter 22
Silent Night deadly night all right guys
now this was the holiday-themed
mid-season finale of season 2 and it
seems that we all must have been on the
naughty list because this episode was
one big lump of confusing coal boy no
not that coal I love that coal now to
help you all feel better about this
silent fright I'm stuffing your
stockings with exclusive
behind-the-scenes secrets from Vanessa
Morgan Lilly Reinhardt we'll be talking
all about Archie and Betty and Cole
Sprouse is spilling a jelly bean update
that you don't want to miss but first
let's rehash the episodes biggest
headlines in the blue and gold breakdown
first up the black hoods identity was
revealed I think I didn't see it in his
eyes now Betty and Archie took the lead
in this week and the duo discovered that
Betty's grandfather was actually one of
the men who killed the Riverdale Reaper
by burying him alive the only problem is
that janitor Svendsen I mean Joseph
Conway I silently sentenced the wrong
man to death from keep dad
now one thing led to another and the
black hood ordered Betty to bury Archie
alive honestly I have no idea why any of
this was happening but I do know that it
was revealed that janitor Svendsen was
hiding under the black hood lame it
wasn't enough
alright guys I don't know about you but
I think this was a major letdown now
I've got a feeling that there's a twist
coming and that Svendsen was just
pretending to be the black hood and that
the real one is still out there but
either way I'm really sick of this
storyline your reindeer games are over
now the other big headline of the night
was when Jughead rallied the younger
members of the Serpent's to drive
drug-dealing penny Peabody out of town
are you willing to risk your necks to
save my dad's life now to make sure that
the snake charmer stays gone for good
they stripped her of her serpent status
literally that tattoo doesn't make you
the surface now I was shocked to see
Jughead slice off Penny's tattoo from
her arm but did you know that that was
originally going to be Tony with the
knife here's the behind-the-scenes scoop
from Vanessa Morgan when I found out
they were gonna be kidnapping her I was
like that's so badass
I loved it you know I think Eddie
Peabody like deserved it Oh completely
it was actually crazy hilarious putting
on those masks and like doing the kidnap
thing I was like I feel like I'm
actually he was like in a weird feller
type room and I'm doing something really
bad right now we're storming up to her
putting a bag over her head they
obviously didn't show it but John had
cut off her tattoo when I saw that like
I literally like screamed you were
grabbing her originally behead him
written this script for my character did
that and they ended up changing it which
makes more sense and yes I've done it
but you know at first when I saw that I
was like wow Tony get it like you're
really you know fun back all right guys
are you glad that Jughead did the honors
shout out your thoughts to me in the
comments below and let's move on to some
romance news in this week 7 seconds in
heaven now following last week's breakup
Bonanza things were all kinds of awkward
between barchi and bug-head as they
tried to spread the holiday cheer and
haven't you heard we're still friends
now Rani gave Archie a super-nice watch
that she had engraved before the
break-up oh and speaking of tiny issues
she also gifted our chickens with those
three little words I love you too
but it was a little too late because
this was after the fact that Archie and
betty kissed in the car during the black
hood crusade I needed Betty compress
right that's right guys we had a bar Qi
smooch and I'm really not sure how to
process this news so let's take a look
at what Lilly Reinhardt had to tell me
about her thoughts on Archie's gift to
Betty for Christmas I loved the gift
that Archie gives Betty in the scene
that was such a touching and sentimental
moment what did that mean for you and
you read that in the script it just it
shows to me there's just such a genuine
friendship between them and you're just
like they just know each other and even
though you don't get to see every little
detail of their past or their history
when she says that you know they listen
to it when they were 5 years old it's
like it just paints a picture for you of
how long these people have been in one
another's lives and it's just it's
really sweet now I agree that they are
wonderful friends but does that mean
that they should be more than that tell
me your thoughts in the comments as we
jump straight into this is and kisses
all right guys
first up in hisses yeah that one's going
straight to the entire black hoods
storyline especially the trip to sister
Mary's because I think that was a
confusing and sloppy storytelling moment
and if Janet Espenson really is the
black hood then to me this whole thing
was a major letdown and a big waste of
time for season two sorry not sorry
dear God can you please get this torture
over with hisses to Betty for keeping
the black hood from the flames girl let
those memories burn and to the fact that
we didn't learn the lodge family secrets
do we have a deal we do daddykins
what was the deal daddykins what has
Veronica gotten herself wrapped up in I
guess time will only tell hisses - the
fact that Archie and Betty were kissing
and it's not because I don't like barchi
truthfully I'm still undecided on them
my hisses - the fact that they both just
got out of a breakup in fact I don't
even think that Jughead knew that they
were broken up
Betty and I had them in the greatest
place either I'm telling you guys our
Ross Keller moment is coming I just know
it
[Music]
and my last hiss is tashera's mom and
her random hookup with Vic the Christmas
tree guy on the flip side here's a kiss
to discovering that Nana Rose blossom is
alive but she's a huge Christmas Grinch
you should've drowned them at birth like
a basket of kittens kisses to these
super thoughtful gifts that Betty and
Jughead gave each other kisses to moose
for making a triumphant return and
kisses to Kevin for teaming up with
Josie and showing us that he can sing
what can't Kevin do and my last kiss of
the night goes to the fact the F P and
Jughead finally talked about jellybean
and their mysterious mom your mom
jellybean now here's what Cole Sprouse
had to tell me when I grilled him yet
again about when we're finally going to
meet the other members of the Jones
family I'm gonna ask you the question
that a million people have been asking
you what's the jelly bean update jelly
bean update yeah interesting we don't
know anything about jelly bean just yet
if this is one of those dilemmas that I
think we face because we have such a
massive ensemble of characters and
oftentimes I think some characters
deserve more justice narrative Li and
what then what we're able to provide in
the first nine episodes so the
introduction of additional characters is
kind of a dilemma that we have because
it means possibly less screen time for
characters who already haven't got
enough I don't know if you know too much
about poor jugheads tormented family
just yet one of these days oh you know
it's gonna get sadder that's for tonight
alright guys now that does it for this
week's Sweetwater secrets and since that
was the last episode of 2017 I won't see
you river babes until next year when
Riverdale returns with the rest of
season two but have no fear follow me on
Twitter because I'll be announcing the
date for a special live episode of
Sweetwater secrets where we'll be doing
a huge round of hisses and kisses for
the entire season so get excited because
I'll also have plenty of Riverdale
secrets that you can only find here now
in the meantime share Sweetwater secrets
with your friends over this winter break
hit me up in the comments to tell me
what you think of the black hood reveal
if you're warming up to the idea of
Archie and Betty as a couple and of
course your top hisses and kisses for
episode 209 now have a wonderful and
safe New Year river babes many many many
mistletoe kisses to you bye guys
[Music]
you